bonjour à tous on est aujourd'hui devant
le stand de copro directement aux 6es à
vegas et on va voir de nouveaux produits
[Musique]
alors d'un côté vous avez là 06 black
s'annonce vraiment comme étant la
nouvelle go pro qui va vraiment déchiré
et maintenant la caméra à 360 degrés
medingo pro et la fusion qui est tout
simplement dingue
[Musique]
oui
donc là on est avec alexandre alexandre
est ce que tu peux nous parler de ces
deux nouveaux produits la gopro heroes 6
et la fusion tout à fait alors la gopro
hero 6 cell est sorti en septembre enfin
4k 60 rames par seconde une
stabilisation énorme
enfin il ya plein de nouvel axe de
stabilisation directement dans la caméra
ce qui fait que même si on la tient la
main comme ceci le foot est pas
complètement droit enfin ça bouge pas
même sur une action car effectivement
avec l'héritier mouvement saclay corrige
fat les chorus vraiment beaucoup
c'est vraiment impressionnant avec il ya
en fait une autre technique est dedans
qui est du rollins auteur sont
cancérigènes
ok on note le rôle initiateur et là
c'est vraiment ça change des choses
vraiment sur la caméra
[Musique]
c'est exact quand même chose pour les
mêmes technologiques ont pesé sur la
fusion donc la fusion la caméra 360 de
gaufres au wii 2 de lentilles une de
chaque côté qui permet de fumer tout à
360 ça sort du 5.2 cas ans ferrique à 30
premières secondes ou du 3/15 60 des
images à 7 à 18 mégapixels tous super
bien super bien ensemble et enfin ça
c'est reconnu la qualité d'assemblage
de la caméra vraiment énorme et avec ça
on est dans la dernière technique
comment tout cela on appelle ça un lover
capture en fait qu'est ce que permet de
faire une caméra 360 on peut capturer
soit 360 ayant gardé dans un cas c'est
très bien mais l'autre chose c'est qu'on
va pouvoir cadrer à la post production
donc tu fais nous tous et uqar à la post
production mais ça on appelle ça un
lover capture et on a sorti la version
mobile de ceux ci ce qui veut dire qu'on
va éviter qu'on se fait par exemple de
la post prod je peux me dire je veux
suivre le mouvement s'étende pas un mec
qui en moto dans ce qu'ils voient et un
moment ce que tu sur les caméras
derrière exact on est en fait c'est
complètement transparent tu fais ça et
que le mobile et tu as utilisé le giro
du mobile pour pouvoir faire ton cadrage
c'est le mobile 80 et faire ceci
ça c'est la version que dirait rapide
par mobile tu peux le faire en version
plus professionnelle ou en utilisant les
plugins pour qu'on a développée par un
pont première il permet d'avoir une
caméra virtuelle dans ton 360 dire je
veux ça je veux ça je veux ça est
derrière tu conduiras une vidéo standard
genève et aura un cadre et à la post
production qui est quelque chose qui est
complètement nouveau
d'accord donc ça tu peux l'avoir dont
première le final cut pro x est aussi
fan un peu trop alors final cut avantage
c'est que final cut lui-même la dernière
version
ils ont supporté le 360 ils ont déjà un
bon claudine qui fait ça donc il suffira
d'en porter le master 360 cadres ap
génial avec mon bilan fait un bon boulot
cool merci beaucoup alexandre merci bon
show salut
voilà un peu ce qu'on peut dire
aujourd'hui sur ces deux nouveaux
produits de go pro dites moi ce que vous
en pensez en commentaire est ce que vous
êtes déjà client de ses co prouesse que
ces produits pourraient vous intéresser
mark et moi tout ça j'ai hâte de
discuter avec vous je vous remercie de
regret cette vidéo vous avez bien
évidemment à l'essai des jolies pousse à
vous abonner et je vous donne rendez
vous très bientôt
ciao
[Musique]